Hai everyone, welcome to this powerful presentation on diabetes, my name is Bury and Songo.
Ladies and gentlemen of excellence, today's agenda is very simple. Help ask your questions about diabetes,
explain different types of diabetes, explain high blood sugar levels, and also help outline how you can manage your diabetes.
To begin with, what is diabetes?
Diabetes is a chronic condition where the body either doesn't produce enough insulin or can't use it effectively.
These leads to high blood sugar levels that are two main types of diabetes, type 1 and type 2 diabetes.
You may be wondering, what are the signs and symptoms of diabetes?
You may be diagnosed with diabetes after you go to your doctor because, increased the test, frequent urination, extreme hunger, and explained weight loss, fatigue, blood division, slow healing source, frequent infections, tingling or numbness, enhanced stroke feed, and of course dry skin.
What are the different types of diabetes?
We have type 1 diabetes, which is autoimmune, orphan diagnosis in youth, we have type 2 diabetes, which is linked to lifestyle and genetics, more common in adults,
We also have got the gestation of diabetes, which develops during pregnancy, usually in the second or third trimester, positive hormonal changes, and of course affecting insulin use, causing high blood sugar levels.
Yoga will perhaps be asking yourself, what are these high blood sugar levels?
Well, high blood sugar levels, or hypogrecemia, occur when there's too much glucose in the blood due to insufficient insulin or insulin resistance.
Another critical question is, what causes high blood sugar levels?
High blood sugar levels are caused when the body doesn't produce enough insulin or can't use it effectively.
Insulin is the hormone that helps remove glucose from the blood into cells for energy.
Without enough insulin, glucose builds up in the bloodstream.
Now, what should be ideal blood sugar level?
A fasting blood sugar level should be between 3.9 to 5.5 minimal per litre.
One to two hours after eating, it should be less than 7.8 minimal per litre.
HBA1C should be less than 5.7%.
For people with diabetes, fasting blood sugar level should be between 4.4 to 7.2 minimal per litre.
One to two hours after eating, it should be less than 10.0 minimal per litre.
For HBA1C, it should be less than 7%.
When should you do your blood tests?
For fasting, it's done after 8 hours without eating.
For random, anytime, regardless of meals.
For OTT, that is oral glucose tolerance test, it's done before and after breaking a sugar solution.
For HBA1C test, it is done able 2 to 3 months to check average blood sugar levels of a time.
If, for instance, you are diagnosed with diabetes, what type of diet should you eat?
Well, fast and foremost, we should consider eating a balanced diet, which is rich in all grains, vegetables,
leany proteins, leany proteins include poll tree, red meat, numb them, and also health fats.
Limit sugar foods, refined carbs, and processed items, and also control portion sizes
to help keep your blood sugar stable.
Do people normally consider doing some sports and exercise?
If not, then be aware that sports and exercise help manage diabetes by lowering blood sugar levels.
They improve insulin sensitivity and also aid weight control.
Regular physical activity also boosts overall health and also reduces the risk of complications.
If you happen to be diabetic, what type of medication will you need?
Good, the medication for diabetes may include oral drugs like BP-P4 inhibitor, such as ologlyptin,
alpha-gloxides in inhibitors like acabose, and does include the metformin, which in most cases is the first line of treatment.
We also have insulin injection, if the body doesn't produce enough insulin.
The choice, however, depends on the diabetes type and individual needs.
Now, that marked the end of my presentation.
And I just want to take this opportunity to thank you Ladies and Gentlemen of Excellence
for paying attention and watching my presentation.
I highly welcome you for any questions, comments, or suggestions.
Thank you and I'm very grateful for you people.